we're already a little bit into the
month of July so it's high time for an
update video in which I'll talk about
what we had going on in June which is
quite a lot and what we've got coming up
in July that you might be interested in
I always like to begin by talking about
three big things so big thing number one
is that I'm hoping to bring out an
asynchronous class on Plato's dialogues
in the study with Sadler Academy it
should be covering a lot of cool stuff
I'll tell you about that in the July
section big thing number two I put out a
video that I'm looking to get still more
feedback on you'll find it linked below
and it was asking for a favor if you've
ever had my videos assigned to you in an
academic class or if you're a professor
who's used my videos in your classes I'm
looking to hear from you and I'll be
putting out a blog post about that as
well trying to gather some information
and get a sense of the impact that the
channel the videos have had big thing
number three we've got this coming up
before too long really about halfway
through the month there is a new series
called conversations with modern
stoicism and I have been asked to be the
second presenter in that I'm going to be
talking about a really important topic
that I think is often misunderstood
about how stoics should look at bad
things happening to other people and
what sort of attitudes they ought to
have about that so those are the three
big things there's a lot of other stuff
that we'll talk about in the July
section but let's talk about June now
so I thought that June was going to be a
month that I'd get caught up on
everything because I don't have any
academic classes running this time
around this summer but as it so happened
it was uh quite packed with a lot of
things some of which are carrying
forward into July quite a few events
there were some conference presentations
the American philosophical practitioners
Association I presented at their annual
meeting virtually the video for that is
down below in the video description and
I presented about uh anger and Anger
Management and Resources in primarily
ancient philosophy and then shortly
after that I was at the Aristotle in the
Aristotelian tradition conference here
hosted at Marquette University and I
presented on what logos means for us
because that's the kind of animal we are
irrational or speech using animal and
unpack that video for that is also below
we had our usual events worlds of
speculative fiction we Revisited uh CJ
chera's Alliance Union narrative
universe and looked at the merchanter
novels we had wisdom for Life show
focused on digital piracy I did some
story time you know with with Dr Sadler
we also had the AMA as usual and the
other kinds of events meeting for the
public Hegel stuff and we also got on
the road and went out to Ohio to see the
Cure which was a really excellent
concert we also went to Summerfest here
in Milwaukee the world's largest Music
Festival unfortunately all the metal was
basically concentrated in one night so
uh me and my my oldest child went to
that and had a great time
um I've been teaching an online
Aristotle course as well and that's been
going uh quite well
um on the moral virtues and I
participated in this uh ongoing set of
workshops and coaching things called
leap which is about uh non-profit
leadership because you know I'm involved
in modern stoicism still after stepping
down as editor of stoicism today and
um with a bunch of other things here in
the Milwaukee area as well and towards
the end of the month I I wound up
getting a little bit sick had to go on
antibiotics and many of you know
sometimes the Cure is not worse than the
disease but certainly takes it out of
you so there was all of that going on I
did get some workouts in a lot of walks
as you've seen you probably also seeing
the pictures of me going to the cat
shelter almost home and you know
enjoying spending time and devoting some
attention and love and care to these
rescued cats so that's that's a lot of
the things that have been going on here
I did a lot of video work
um You probably have seen quite a few
videos on Philip K Dick's great novel
The Man in the High Castle so I've been
doing uh a lot of uh filming for that
and some half hour Hegel I didn't get as
much done this month as I was hoping but
we've still got some forward momentum so
we're making our way through absolute
knowing I did a Twitter conversation
that was was a pretty decent and then we
did another ideas that matter uh
interview video with my good friend
Scott to ruli talking about the music
industry and philosophy and his new
mentoring program that he's been doing I
released an evil Sadler video or maybe
we should say evil Sadler managed to
slip out of his bonds and uh start
spouting his usual BS I did a couple
Sandler stories videos talking about my
own memory degrees and you know some
some things that people might find
interesting and I did that video about
asking for a favor so if you have seen
my videos been assigned them in your
academic classes or if you're an
instructor and you've assigned them I'd
love to find out from you when and where
and and you know what videos you
actually encountered or used I did a
book review video I've been trying to
get to book reviews for quite a while
and it's a good one on how to tell a
joke which is a wonderful little
translation
I also released a bunch of old wisdom
for life they weren't videos yet they
were only podcasts and I put them to
some pictures so that I could then fill
out the uh the entire podcast slash
playlist which is important and I did a
video that is already getting a lot of
views doing an update you know 10 years
ago roughly 10 years ago it was in May
of 2013. I did a video specifically
about my experience as somebody who
deals with depression and that got a lot
of views and a lot of comments and so it
was time to do you know a
reconsideration of that so I I did a
video specifically on that and it's got
quite a good reception I would say
and you know you can find that down
below as well and then a lot of podcast
work in the Sadler's lectures podcast we
finished up with seneca's on shortness
of life really great work that I love to
teach and then finished out the sequence
on on anger with the ones on book three
then we jump to Marcus aurelius's
meditations and we're still in process
of releasing those and meanwhile in the
background these have already been
released to my patreon supporters at
least some of them I've been doing some
others on tolkien's great essay on fairy
stories right so we're getting into
fantasy speculative fiction and literary
criticism literary studies right so that
is what went on in the month of June
it's hard to believe that we are now
past the halfway point of the year but
we are indeed in July we've got a lot of
events coming up this month some of them
local some of them online that you can
easily participate in so we kick off on
the 8th that's a Saturday at noon with
my monthly AMA that's asked me anything
session and you're welcome to show up
and ask whatever questions you want to
on the eighth as well after that for
patreon supporters you can always become
a patreon supporter if this is something
you want to do we have our philosophy
chat which is a little bit more intimate
video conferencing on the ninth I will
be doing another story time with Sadler
telling or actually reading one of my
long time favorite short stories and
this one is the king of cats so you
might get a kick out of that on the 12th
which is a Wednesday at 5 PM we'll have
our public Hegel q a and discussion
underwritten by supporters of the half
hour Hegel project and then on the 15th
we've got sort of a double header at
nine in the morning uh central time we
will be having the conversations with
modern stoicism hosted by modern
stoicism there's already 300 people
signed up for it I think or perhaps I'm
mistaking that with how many people were
signed up for the the previous one but
it's going to be a big big thing there's
like breakout sessions I'm going to be
the person sort of setting the topic but
there's lots of opportunity for
conversation with other people you don't
have to identify as a stoic if you're
stoic curious it's a great thing to show
up to this is sort of an Outreach that
modern stoicism does so that is on the
15th 9 A.M and then at 12 p.m same day
okay on the 15th we will have worlds of
speculative fiction we begin with a
video premiere and this time we're
talking about C L Moore and her girol of
jewelry stories which are really
wonderful
fantasy weird fiction stuff from the
Golden Age and it's a really interesting
compelling character on the 21st
um here locally at the Women's Club of
Wisconsin philosophy eats we have a
dinner and I provide some conversation
starters drawn from philosophy that's
always a lot of fun that is a local
event that that people would have to
sign up for then on the 22nd coming back
to online events at 12 p.m noon Central
time understanding anger we're going to
be looking at the first systematic
treatment of anger in the west and that
is by Aristotle in rhetoric book two
we're going to really explore a rhetoric
book two talking about anger and its
opposite and also some related emotions
like hatred and how that's different
from anger and then we'll finish up on
the 29th with something that I didn't
get to this last month but I'm really
happy to get to this time and that's
another self-directed study advice video
this time it's about David Hume somebody
who you know I'm not a human but I'm a
fan of the guy and I think you ought to
be as well got a lot going on this month
I'm hoping to get back to the gym more
regularly and get in a lot more walks
and Hikes and stuff like that to enjoy
the wonderful environment that we've got
here we're also doing something
and when I say we I mean me and my wife
who I met first in high school uh at
Catholic Memorial we're going to be
going back for my 35th reunion I've
never gone to any of them we're not
going to the whole shebang we're just
going to one event and it should be
quite interesting maybe I'll put some
you know writing down my my thoughts
about what it's like to run into people
really half a lifetime later you know I
mean 35 years is a long time I've got a
lot of writing to do including working
on a textbook for one of the classes I'm
teaching this coming semester at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
ethics for artists and designers I've
already started outlining that it's
obviously not going to be completely
finished by the time that I start but
they're good the students will be my
proverbial guinea pigs for that
um video work so you know I'm gonna try
to make some more progress with the half
hour Hegel project the end is in sight
we're making our way through the very
last section absolute knowing the half
hour Hegel project will probably be
finished either in August or September
I've got a lot of book review videos to
do and I'm looking forward to catching
up on those got to finish up the Philip
K dick man in the High Castle still
quite a few videos yet to go to
completely exhaust that work
then I'm going to be doing some core
concept videos as well and I've long
wanted to do a set on aquinas's five
ways and then after that I'm going to
begin something that will will start in
July and it'll probably continue through
August and perhaps even September and
that's a work that a lot of people have
asked me about for quite a while and I'm
finally going to get to it and you know
ideally do core concept videos on every
part of it Emmanuel kantz prologomina to
any future metaphysics so an important
work to do
I'll do some Sadler stories videos I'm
sure as things you know occur to me and
I'm like yeah that would be a good thing
to talk about uh got some more
interviews lined up and I'll do some
more personal videos as well I think so
that should be a lot of fun and then
finally the podcast so I mentioned that
I've already released to patreon
supporters uh some of the episodes on
tolkien's uh on fairy stories which is a
incredibly important work in
understanding fantasy fiction from one
of the great Masters himself and I'll be
releasing those to the public fairly
soon I'm also going to do some other
speculative fiction stuff uh you know
Philip K dicks the Android and the human
I've got some videos on those that I
want to convert into podcasts and then
finally I'm going to start uh with
Ursula Kayla green and her Earthsea the
series on what you know I did a whole
bunch of videos those are going to start
getting converted to podcasts as well
and that should probably you know get us
started uh we'll start that in July and
then it'll continue on for a while as
well so a lot going on this month as
always I hope that you can join me for
some of these online events and consider
uh oh I almost forgot to mention the
Plato class right so this month you will
see another online class
starting enrollment and
um it's a asynchronous so you proceed at
your own pace it will be Plato's
dialogue specifically the youthifro the
uh apology The Credo and the Fado these
are the ones that are surrounding the
trial and death of Socrates so there'll
be videos podcast episodes
handouts lesson Pages all sorts of cool
stuff there to help you learn and make
your way through these really important
platonic dialogues I'll probably have
some other things on the horizon for you
to check out as well I've got some other
classes in the works but I'll say more
about them later on down the line
probably in some videos that I'll shoot
and then you can ask about them then so
I hope all of you have a great month and
maybe join me for some of these online
events if you can and I hope that you
keep on studying philosophy and getting
something out of the authors that you're
studying and maybe some of my resources
will help you in that Quest